ça faisait un petit moment déjà que
j'avais envie de vous parler d'un
philosophe philosophe que j'ai découvert
il ya quelques années après mes études
de philosophie et qui m'a pas laissé
indifférent et dont je peux même dire
que cette année mais philosophe favori
ce philosophe c'est et schopenhauer
c'est un philosophe allemand du 18ème et
19ème siècle et c'est un homme qui avait
une vision du monde assez original à ses
personnels est assez puissante et
j'aurais souhaité vous l'exposez
brièvement en quelques mots alors
schopenhauer était un penseur à part un
penseur un peu particulier aussi bien
par sa vision du monde que par son
comportement sa manière de faire sa
manière de s'exprimer par exemple c'est
quelqu'un qui n'hésitait pas à attaquer
frontalement y compris par l'insultent
ceux avec lesquels il était en désaccord
à l'époque de schopenhauer le philosophe
le plus en vue le plus réputé et le prix
appréciait c'était eagle et schopenhauer
n'hésitez pas à se moquer de hegel qu'il
qualifiait de philosophe universitaire
pour lui l'université à cette époque
n'était qu'un prolongement de
l'idéologie de l'état
il s'inscrivait complètement contre
l'institution contre l'enseignement
universitaire contre la philosophie
officiel et on comprend que il est plus
aussi développé une certaine forme de
frustration de ne pas être reconnue de
son temps comme un grand esprit un
philosophe à part entière alors je vous
disais que schopenhauer avait une vision
du monde originale
quelle était cette vision du monde cette
vision du monde il leur la développe
elle expose dans son ouvrage le plus
connu un ouvrage assez monumentale le
monde comme volonté et comme
représentation caisse
ahmadian bien pour schopenhauer le monde
tel que nous le connaissons tel que nous
le voyons tels que nous l'étudions n'est
pas d'une certaine manière le vrai monde
c'est plutôt la coquille du monde
une facette du monde ce qu'on pourrait
appeler la face externe du monde et
c'est ça qu'il appelle la représentation
ce monde de la représentation
c'est le monde que nous percevons que
nous analysons et auquel nous essayons
de donner un sens notamment par la
science par l'intellect par la raison
dans ce monde qui est le nôtre
les choses ont un sens les choses
obéissent à la loi de la causalité au
principe de raison suffisante c'est à
dire que une cause produit un effet et
aucun effet n'existe sans cause rien
n'arrive sans raison et on peut rendre
raison de tout ce qui arrive ça c'est la
vision scientifique du monde qu'on
pourrait appeler la la vision
matérialiste du monde
schopenhauer lui échappe totalement à
ces catégories de matérialisme ou
d'idéalisme
il se situe au delà ce monde la
représentation c'est également le monde
de l'espace et du temps
c'est à dire que nous sommes dans un
monde où tout s'inscrit nécessairement
dans l'espace et le temps
on ne peut pas se représenter quelque
chose en dehors de l'espace laisse
passer pour un citoyen la structure même
de notre esprit et de la même façon
pas se représenter les choses sans
espaces hors de l'espace on ne peut pas
se les représente et non plus en dehors
du temps tout est soumis à une
chronologie il y a toujours un avant et
un après et un pendant mais on ne peut
pas penser en dehors de cette idée de
temporalité on peut pas penser disons
l'éternité
d'ailleurs quand on pense le temps on
imagine toujours sous une forme diviser
le passé le présent et l'avenir
et si on y réfléchit bien le
c'est l'avenir n'existe pas puisqu'ils
sont des représentations mentales
la seule chose qui existe c'est le
présent et pour schopenhauer la seule
chose qui existe réellement
au delà du monde de la représentation
c'est l'instant et l'instant c'est
l'éternité
alors si je veux vous faire comprendre
exactement ce que je peux y avoir appel
la représentation je vais être obligé de
passer par ce qu'il appelle la volonté
alors qu'est ce que la volonté est bien
c'est en quelque sorte la face interne
du monde ce que le philosophe quant à
pied la chose en soi et qui est pour et
on dit en le fond insaisissable de la
réalité
le fonds insaisissable c'est à dire
c'est quelque chose dans réalité qui ne
peut pas être conçue par l'esprit qui ne
peut pas être saisi par l'intellect
c'est quelque chose qui échappe
complètement à nos capacités de
compréhension
j'ai dit tout à l'heure que nous
pensions et nous nous représentons les
choses toujours à travers deux
catégories qui sont l'espace et le temps
on ne peut pas penser en dehors de ces
catégories bien la volonté c'est
justement ce qui est en dehors de
l'espace et du temps
c'est donc ce qui échappe à nos
catégories de représentation à nos
catégories de pensée donc c'est quelque
chose qui est totalement insaisissables
pour nous par les outils de l'intellect
au complet
ma présentation la volonté c'est la
source de notre monde physique de notre
monde matériel observable ce que
schopenhauer appelle le mans de la
représentation donc et c'est ce qui
anime le monde de la représentation pour
schopenhauer le monde de la
représentation
c'est l'expression du monde de la
volonté alors le mot expression est
intéressant parce que si on le décompose
expression ça signifie ce qui est poussé
en dehors en quelque sorte
donc le monde à la représentation c'est
ce qui est poussé par le monde de la
volonté c'est la surface visible de la
volonté et c'est la seule réalité à
laquelle en fait nous ayons accès je
vais essayer de le dire encore autrement
pour schopenhauer la volonté ces lettres
intimes du monde tandis que la
représentation le monde de la
représentation
c'est la surface du monde c'est la
pellicule externe du monde
pour prendre une image c'est un peu
comme si je parlais de l'océan et bien
la représentation de l'océan c'est sa
surface c'est ce qu'on envoie c'est ce
qui est à l'extérieur c'est ce qui est
exprimé tandis que la volonté de l'océan
et bien ce sont plutôt les fonds
sous-marins et la surface de l'eau
c'est l'expression des fonds sous-marins
qui eux ne sont inaccessibles ils le
sont en réalité puisqu'on peut plonger
sous l'eau mais pour schopenhauer on ne
peut pas plonger dans la volonté on est
obligé de rester dans la surface de la
représentation
donc si on poursuit le fil de la pensée
de schopenhauer
en réalité nous ne connaissons pas
vraiment le monde nous connaissons sa
surface nous connaissons sa pellicule
externe
nous connaissons la représentation la
représentation alors je vais peut-être
en dire quelques mots
et c'est ce qui fait que par exemple si
je vois une bouteille doit en face de
moi pour moi c'est une bouteille d'eau
points ce n'est rien d'autre que ce que
j'en vois je peux la touche et je peux
la mesure et je peut la décrire
et pour moi c'est la seule réalité en
tant que sujet pensant en tant qu'être
qui a une conscience je perçois le monde
autour de moi et je ne me dis pas ce
monde c'est la représentation
pour moi c'est le monde c'est le seul
monde qui existent ça c'est que
très bien par cho power par le fait que
précisément l'homme n'est pas capable
d'aller au delà du monde de la
représentation
en tout cas il n'est pas capable par les
outils de l'intellect donc quand par
exemple les scientifiques produisent un
savoir et produisent un savoir sur la
réalité sur la réalité physique sur la
réalité matérielle produisent un savoir
sur le monde de la représentation
évidemment ce monde à la représentation
il peut très bien nous suffire
on peut se contenter de ce moment là en
se disant après tout c'est le monde dans
lequel j'évolue
je n'ai pas de raison de vouloir
chercher une espèce d'arrière mondou
dessous monde où deux mondes primordial
puisque le monde la représentation nous
convient très bien
c'est vrai mais pour schopenhauer ce
monde à la représentation c'est aussi un
monde d'illusions
c'est un monde d'illusions puisque c'est
un monde qui nous fait croire que nous
sommes supérieurs à ce que nous sommes
réellement alors expliquons sans l'être
humain pause
sciences il possède à l'intellect
l'intellect
c'est ce qui fait que l'homme est un
animal supérieur c'est un animal qui a
la capacité de se représenter
intellectuellement le monde
il est capable de sang former des images
conceptuelles donc pour schopenhauer
l'homme c'est un animal conceptuel c'est
à dire un animal qui a la conscience
intellectuelle du monde de la
représentation du monde dans lequel il
vit mais ce monde est une illusion parce
que quoi que nous fassions est aussi
élevée soit nos capacités
intellectuelles
nous pouvons comprendre le comment du
monde comment elle fonctionne c'est le
travail des scientifiques en utilisant
le principe de causalité chaque cause
produit un effet nous pouvons comprendre
ce monde dans son fonctionnement dans
ses mécanismes
mais nous sommes incapables d'en
comprendre le pourquoi nous sommes
incapables d'en comprendre le sens
pourquoi
parce que pour comprendre le sens du
monde dans son intimité il faudrait être
capable de pénétrer le monde de la
volonté et ça nous n'y avons pas accès
donc tout ce qu'on va dire à partir de
maintenant ne sera qu'une manière de
confirmer qu en fait ne pouvons rien
dire de ce monde de la volonté on va
quand même essayer alors une idée
importante que développe schopenhauer
c'est que ce monde la volonté nous en
avons une connaissance indirecte puisque
le monde de la représentation est en
quelque sorte le moyen par lequel le
monde de la volonté se manifeste se
révèle ce rang connaissable se rend
accessible à nos consciences nous mêmes
en tant qu'individu en tant que sujets
humains nous sommes des manifestations
de la volonté nous en sommes des
produits des productions donc si l'homme
était capable de se connaître lui-même
il serait capable de connaître un aspect
de la volonté
l'aspect sous lequel la volonté se
manifeste à travers lui alors il ya
quand même quelque chose que l'on peut
connaître de l'homme c'est le fait
qu'ils vivent donc la vie est au coeur
du monde de la représentation puisque
nous en avons une connaissance et là
encore comme pour la volonté nous savons
grosso modo comment la vie fonctionne
mais nous ne savons pas pourquoi il ya
de la vie et ça c'est le problème
fondamental de la volonté elle se laisse
connaître dans ses modalités de
fonctionnement à travers le monde la
représentation elle se laisse pas
connaître à travers sa raison d'être
pour schopenhauer la volonté n'a pas de
raison d'être de la même façon que la
vie n'a pas de raison d'être
elle et c'est tout ce qu'on peut en dire
elle est à travers nous elle est autour
de nous elle est avant nous et après
nous mais nous ne pouvons rien savoir de
son pourquoi ne pouvons rien savoir de
sa finalité puisque sa finalité c'est
simplement de se perpétuer dans le temps
la volonté et hors du temps on l'a dit
tout à l'heure dans le monde la
représentation elle est donc
intemporelle elle se perpétue
indéfiniment et les individus que nous
sommes ne sont que les moyens par
lesquels la vie et la volonté se
perpétue
la volonté c'est une sorte d'énergie
informe chaotique éternel infini qui se
propage à travers les choses et les
êtres vivants
comment rendre cette idée un peu
compréhensible bien en disant que chacun
admet que nous avons ce qu'on appelle
instinct de survie
l'instinct de survie c'est ce qui fait
que dans des situations notre vie sera
menacée nous allons mettre une espèce de
stratégie inconsciente pour rester dans
la vie pour nous maintenir dans
l'existence et cet instinct de survie en
tant qu'instance il est d'origine
animale il n'est pas rationnel il n'est
pas logique
on ne sait même pas pourquoi on a cet
instinct de survie et on ne sait même
pas pourquoi on lui obéit et pourtant on
lui obéit l'instinct de survie c'est
donc une forme de la volonté qui se
manifeste de manière individualisée pour
nous les êtres humains de la même façon
qu'on ne sait pas pourquoi nous voulons
survivre mais que nous cherchons à
survivre et bien la volonté nous ne
savons pas pourquoi elle est là mais
elle est là et elle se perpétue à
travers nous elle n'a pas de raison
d'être
elle n'a pas de logique elle n'a pas de
sens son sens c'est seulement de se
perpétuer et c'est ça pour schopenhauer
qui est tragique c'est à dire que nous
avons conscience qu'il y a de la vie
mais nous ne comprenons pas pourquoi il
ya de la vie il y a de la volonté mais
ne comprenons pas pourquoi y ait la
volonté pour schopenhauer
l'homme est victime d'une illusion
fondamental c'est qu'il pourrait être
libre il croit que il décide lui même de
ses agissements et qu' il est le maître
de sa vie qu'il est le maître de ses
actes que c'est lui qui a le contrôle
les individus se croient libres alors
qu'ils ne sont que l'expression
localiser de la volonté
en fait nous tous
être humain tu nous sommes on se rend
pas compte qu'on travaille pour la
volonté c'est à dire qu'on travaille à
la perpétuation d'une vie qu'on ne
comprend pas qui n'a pas de sens qui n'a
pas de pourquoi
et malgré tout nous faisons nous
déployons tous nos efforts pour
perpétuer cette vie une vie dont
schopenhauer guy d'ailleurs qu'elle est
d'abord source de souffrance
schopenhauer il ya beaucoup plus de
souffrance que de bonheur dans la vie
et malgré cette souffrance nous
continuons nous persistons à vouloir
perpétuer une ville en sachant qu'elle
va nous rendre malheureux en sachant
qu'on ne peut pas en comprendre le sens
et en sachant qu'elle nous échappe
totalement
alors pour ceux qui connaissent la
référence le film usual suspects
c'est une bande de malfrats qui se
retrouva à devoir rendre des comptes sur
une tuerie qui a lieu sur un sur un
bateau et apparaît un moment donné le
nom du du malfrat ultime qui s'appelle
kaiser sozé kaiser sozé c'est la figure
du duc union qui qui inspire la terreur
qu'inspire l'effroi et qu'on
souhaiterait surtout par rencontrer et
kaiser sozé sa particularité c'est qu'il
fait travailler des gens qui ignorent
qu'ils travaillent pour lui
si bien que il peut les croiser il peut
leur parler il peut avoir un phare a eu
aucun ne saura qu'il est kaiser sozé
aucun ne saura qu'il est en train de
travailler pour lui à ce moment là eh
bien on peut dire que la volonté c'est
kaiser sozé elle fait travailler les
individus dans le monde de la
représentation sans le leur dire sans
qu'il le sache sans même qu'il puisse le
comprendre
et pourtant ils le font et ils le font
de même ils le font volontairement
lorsqu on reproduit la vie au travail à
perpétuer le monde de la volonté alors
que la volonté ne nous a rien demandé
mais simplement nous sommes l'expression
de là volonté
la vie n'a pas de but autre que se
perpétue elle même
c'est donc que la vie un but sans but
le but c'est se perpétue et se perpétue
et pourquoi on ne sait pas ça n'a pas de
sens et pourtant on se perpétue
on veut vivre mais sans savoir pourquoi
on a un amour aveugle de l'existence qui
nous pousse à vouloir nous maintenir
dans la vie sans savoir pourquoi nous
voulons nous maintenir dans la vie c'est
là qu'on arrive à un aspect très
intéressant de la philosophie de
schopenhauer qui est la question de
l'amour qu'est ce que l'amour
bon ça nous étonnera pas pour
schopenhauer l'amour c'est encore une
illusion
c'est une illusion que la volonté donne
aux individus pour qu'il consente à
perpétuer l'espèce pour qu'il consente à
perpétuer le cycle indéfinie de la vie
lorsque nous sommes amoureux
nous voulons 12 unir à la personne que
nous aimons et de cet amour va naître un
enfant c'est à dire que de cet amour va
naître la vie l'amour c'est donc le
moyen l'instrument qu'utilise l'espèce
et au delà de l'espèce la volonté pour
que la vie puisse se perpétuer donc pour
que la volonté elle-même puisse se
perpétuer
mais vous allez peut-être me dire oui
mais l'amour ce n'est pas ça qui fait
qu'on se reproduit c'est le désir sexuel
qui fait qu'on se reproduit oui et babur
schopenhauer l'amour et le désir sexuel
c'est exactement la même chose en fait
l'amour c'est simplement la forme
culturellement acceptable du désir
sexuel
tout à l'heure je disais que l'homme
était un animal conceptuel mais pour
schopenhauer l'homme et l'animal c'est
exactement la même chose
les deux sont dans une logique de
persévérer dans la vie de se maintenir
dans l'existence les deux possède
l'instinct de survie
les deux se reproduise et au final la
différence la seule différence qu'il ya
entre l'homme et l'animal
ben c'est que l'homme se pose la
question du sens de son existence tandis
que l'animal se contente d'être dans
l'existence donc ça peut nous amener à
nous dire qu'il n'ya pas de souffrance
morale mentale chez les animaux il n'y a
pas deux peut-être pas de dépression
chez les animaux comme il ya de la
dépression chez des êtres humains
puisque l'être humain se pose la
question du sens et en l'absence de
réponse eh bien ça va nécessairement
affectée son rapport à l'existant c'est
donc ça va affecter
sa vie morale mentale affective donc
l'amour je disais c'est la forme
culturellement acceptable du désir
sexuel
par exemple un homme séduit une femme eh
bien il va simplement prendre un chemin
indirectes pour aller vers ce qui est la
finalité c'est à dire le désir sexuel
qui lui même doit conduire à la
reproduction
donc en fait mesdames quand vous fait
draguer et bien l'homme qui vous drague
il cherche à perpétuer l'espèce à
travers vous et si vous acceptez ses
avances vous acceptez de perpétuer
l'espèce à travers lui on peut dire que
le processus de séduction qui est à
l'oeuvre dans dans l'expression du désir
sexuel humains bien ce n'est qu'un d'un
labyrinthe qu un dédale qui finalement
conduire à on le sait nécessairement à
une seule issue qui est la reproduction
alors c'est pour ça que pour beaucoup la
séduction est quelque chose de l'ordre
de l'hypocrisie pour schopenhauer c'est
de l'ordre de l'hypocrisie puisqu'en
fait on sait à l'avancé où ça va mener
ça va mener au lit ça va mener à l'acte
sexuel et l'acte sexuel ayant pour
finalité la reproduction et bien la
séduction va mener à la reproduction
dans l'amour il y a quelque chose qui
vient se surajouter aux désirs sexuels
qu'ils aient le sentiment mais pour
schopenhauer ce sentiment qui a malgré
tout eu c'est vrai un le côté un petit
peu mystérieux eh bien il n'est que ce
qui nous permet d'accepter le fait que
nous soyons prévu et déterminé pour nous
reproduire comme nous sommes des animaux
conceptuel nous sommes des animaux
métaphysique nous sommes des animaux qui
produisons du sens et à l'idée que nous
puissions nous comporter exactement
comme des animaux c'est à dire copuler
bestialement et puis faire en sorte de
laisser une progéniture
après nous c'est quelque chose qui n'est
pas supportable à notre conscience c'est
quelque chose que nous ne sommes pas
prêts à accepter parce que votre vanité
schopenhauer la paix la vanité notre
orgueil nôtre et notre ego
fait que nous nous voulons tellement
nous persuader que nous avons l'emprise
de notre vie de ce que nous faisons de
nos choix et y compris le sentiment que
nous ne pouvons pas accepter cette idée
donc l'amour c'est en quelque sorte le
subterfuge de la nature c'est le
subterfuge de la volonté pour nous faire
consentir à la répétition sans fin du
cycle de la vie mais là encore l'amour
c'est ce qui donne sens à une relation
conjugale
mais derrière tout ça qu'est ce qu'il ya
eh bien il ya la sexualité et pour
schopenhauer la sexualité c'est le fond
primitive de la vie c'est donc
l'expression de là volonté dans son
caractère le plus brut mais aussi le
plus pur puisque à travers la sexualité
bien la volonté se manifeste
tel quel quasiment la sexualité c'est
quelque chose de totalement irrationnel
c'est à dire que si on se pose la
question pourquoi j'ai du désir sexuel
pour cette personne il n'y a pas
d'explication rationnelle on peut que
constater désir on ne peut pas
l'expliquer on ne peut pas expliquer son
pourquoi on peut expliquer son comment
on revient ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure sur la différence entre le
pourquoi et le comment
la volonté c'est le pourquoi on ne peut
pas le connaître
la représentation c'est le comment c'est
la seule chose qu'on puisse connaître
donc on peut éditer et lui
éventuellement les les mécanismes du
désir sexuel et les mécanismes du
fonctionnement sexuel non pourra jamais
expliquer le pourquoi du désir
d'ailleurs schopenhauer là-dessus fait
une petite remarque il dit que c'est
lorsque l'acte sexuel est terminée qu'on
prend conscience de son caractère
absurde
après d'actes sexuels schopenhauer dit
le sentiment de honte qui nous
envahissent c'est un sentiment de
lucidité 1 un sentiment de lucidité sur
la bestialité fondamentales qui nous
constitue et la bestialité fondamental
c'est la volonté puisque c'est cette
force brute qui s'exprime à travers nos
de manière totalement irrationnel et
déchaîné donc
jean c'est la volonté qui s'exprime dans
le désir sexuel est finalement le désert
sexuel c'est peut-être la meilleure
représentation qu'on puisse avoir de la
volonté dans le monde de la
représentation a bien vu que le monde de
la volonté cette espèce de monde
chaotique informe qui structure le monde
de la représentation
il est à connaissable il est
impénétrable mais il se laisse deviner
d'une certaine manière à travers
certains phénomènes et le désir sexuel
c'est vraiment le phénomène humain dans
lequel le monde de la volonté s'exprime
de la manière la plus directe et de la
plus accessible
alors je vais vous lire à un petit
passage de schopenhauer sur sur
l'instinct sexuel
l'instinct sexuel et cause de la guerre
et de la paix il est le fondement
d'action sérieuse objet de plaisanterie
source inépuisable de mots d'esprit clé
de toutes les allusions explications de
tout signe mais de toutes propositions
n'ont formulé de tout regard furtif
c'est que la sphère principal de tous
les hommes se traite en secret et sans
veloppe ostensiblement de la plus grande
ignorance possible deuxième
a sion sur l'amour et la relation entre
l'amour et la sexualité tout inclination
amoureuse n'est qu'un instinct sexuel
plus nettement déterminer plus
individualisé la procréation de tels
enfants déterminer voilà le but
véritable couac ignoré des acteurs de
tout roman d'amour les moyens et la
façon d'y atteindre son choses
accessoires
donc là je pense que c'est suffisamment
clair le but ignoré des amoureux des
amants c'est la reproduction et pas
seulement des amoureux puisque on peut
considérer que tous les êtres humains
ont un jour connu l'amour tous les êtres
humains ont nécessairement connus ce
désir de se perpétuer
en fusionnant en en se conjuguant à une
autre personne ga schopenhauer nous dit
les moyens et la façon d'y atteindre son
choses accessoires on peut employer la
séduction
on peut employer d'autres moyens disons
plus brutaux et et bestiaux dans tous
les cas c'est la vie qui demandent à se
perpétuer
c'est la volonté qui demande à
s'exprimer pour schopenhauer la vie est
une tragédie absolue
c'est une tragédie absolue puisque nous
souffrons le temps nous fait souffrir
l'inconscience nous fait souffrir la
conscience c'est sec
cette impossibilité de de saisir la
réalité ultime qu'est la volonté dans
son essence ne pourra jamais à saisir
on prend jamais la comprendre pourra
jamais en rendre raison et cette rage
il faut la faire cesser la faire cesser
en cessant de procréer purement et
simplement cessé de procréer ccc
d'engendrer des êtres qui connaîtront la
souffrance cc c'est de participer à
cette cette répétition indéfini
perpétuelle de la volonté et c'est faire
preuve de lucidité de compassion pour
schopenhauer lucidité parce que la seule
lucidité à laquelle on puisse accéder
c'est comprendre que le monde n'a pas de
sens c'est comprend que la vie est
absurde c'est comprendre que ce qu'on
fait on le fait sans savoir pourquoi on
le fait on est dans l'ignorance totale
des du sens de notre existence et de nos
actes et si nous avons un tant soit peu
de compassion à l'égard de nous-mêmes et
à l'égard d'autrui qui est un autre nous
mêmes eh bien nous devons cesser de
reproduire indéfiniment ce cycle de vie
voilà bien source
profitez de la vie
[Musique]
et
oh